in the coastal Mexican city of Catemaco
indigenous traditions have mixed with
Catholicism to create a unique brand of
spirituality that sometimes puts spells
ahead of crucifixes people patronize
brujos or witches like Julio Garcia to
remedy physical or emotional pain I cure
many spiritual even physical things if
you have a cold I can take care of it if
you have a bad hip I bandage it
this young lady suffers from headaches
and Hulya treats her by performing a
cleansing ceremony or limpia in the
tradition of ancient folk healers she
may also prescribe specialties or
potions that contain medicinal herbs
like garlic eucalyptus and rosemary the
methods employed are all white magic for
good things
SEIG radicchio is an expert on Mexican
culture who sees magic as integral to
the social fabric
now magical thinking is a unique human
feature in magical practices are
probably as old as mankind itself
they always relate to basic human
questions concerned about a person's
well-being physical and spiritual
well-being of course as well as to his
awareness of his own finiteness but
there is more to the story of Brujeria
than Huli is healing with white magic
when settling a score or getting back at
someone who may need to harness the
power of the dark side black magic
southern us Satan
aim for the infernal stars Astaroth bill
Zebub infernal spirits at this moment I
ask for your presence and intervention
depending on the work to be done one or
another magic is used
by meeting if there is a sentimental
problem then red magic is used if there
is a problem with the neighbor black
magic is more likely to be used to get
rid of someone who is causing harm we
definitely use black magic in black
magic the ritual climax usually involves
a sacrifice SK para que sería kawan Tala
but in order to complete the work the
client asks for at that moment an
offering of blood must be made at that
moment all beings up to the highest
authority are present we can't see them
but we can feel it in the body the
healer and the patient alike to
outsiders the work of Kerameikos brujos
may seem like superstitious nonsense but
as long as members of the community
continue to find benefit in the age-old
tradition the brujos will practice their
white and black magic